how can a country overcome a crisis how
can it reinvent itself change itself and
transform these are two of the questions
you have asked us in the comment section
here on visual politic and well dove
viewer I think we can say that the
economy usually evolves through cycles
that is a growth phase is sooner or
later always followed by a crisis and
then this crisis is followed again by a
new growth phase and so on and so forth
for example since World War two the
United States has undergone 11 complete
economic cycles that is both growth and
crisis years however my friends things
aren't always of that simple sometimes
leaving a crisis is very very hard so
much so that decades could go by so much
so that even a rich and prosperous
country can stop being a rich and
prosperous country because don't think
that this only effects emerging
countries not at all
even the richest countries can suffer
this type of deep crisis usually due to
political reasons or rather bad policies
but yesterday via a country can even
escape these deepest of crises we saw it
here on visual politic with for example
the case of New Zealand which after
undergoing a very harsh crisis managed
to completely overturn the situation
well in this video we're gonna show you
another example and that would be the
example of Canada yep you heard me right
did you know that Canada almost went
bankrupt well if you didn't listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
Canada is one of the richest freest and
most prosperous countries with the
highest quality of life on the planet it
doesn't even matter what ranking we use
it can be the United Nations HDI the
corruption perception index of
transparency international the Fraser
Institute's human freedom Index or the
legato prosperity index in all of them
Canada is always among the highest on
the list but this video isn't about
rankings but before we move on I just do
want to touch on one last one very
quickly see in the latest ranking of the
best countries prepared by US news
magazine and the Wharton School Canada
appears as the second best country to
live in in the world
[Music]
so it's pretty clear as we already saw
it on this channel the Canada dear
viewer is very very popular right now
however things in Canada weren't always
this happy there was a time in the 1960s
and especially in the 1970s where
everything was about to collapse
[Music]
[Applause]
the disaster
for years Canada was very similar to the
United States it was practically it's
twin brother it had a very small
governments the country was very
decentralized and taxes were very
similar of course the idea then was to
compete to attract investments and thus
also people from abroad immigrants
however this all changed in the 1960s at
that time Canada sought to distance
itself from the United States and to try
a new political and economic model the
great architects of this revolution was
Pierre Trudeau yeah that's the father of
the current Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau of course father and sons
politics are by no means the same it
looks like Justin Trudeau certainly did
his homework but let's not straight from
the subject too much
[Music]
the fact is that just introduced father
governed Canada virtually uninterrupted
between 1968 and 1984 and the fact is
that throughout these 16 years in power
the country changed a great deal see
Trudeau senior wanted to implement a new
political model in Canada which was a
bit different from Washington's
capitalism and somewhat closer to so via
Moscow's collectivism
as against the invisible hand of Adam
Smith there has to be a visible hand of
politicians whose objective it is to
have the kind of society that is caring
and humane Pierre Trudeau in fact in
international politics one of the things
the Prime Minister was best known for
was his close friendship with Fidel
Castro in any case the truth is that we
could say that traduz father went a bit
far he raised taxes a lot he increased
public spending he nationalized
companies and because he thought that
all international trade and investment
was bad due to competition he decided to
set up barriers so speaking of barriers
well who does that sound like has
slapped new tariffs on imported wash
machines and solar panels if that wasn't
enough he also made the Central Bank
prints banknotes to spare to expand
credit and finance the government and
well maybe this recipe is starting to
sound a bit familiar to you well
Venezuela's adding more zeros to its
currency releasing bills with larger
denominations
[Music]
well the results of all of this Divya is
that within a few years the deficit
unemployment and inflation rates but the
whole country up against the ropes so of
course when in 1984 Pierre Trudeau left
office he did so with the lowest
popularity level for a Canadian prime
minister in decades only 2 out of every
10 Canadian still supported him and it
was at this time that Canadian citizens
had to make a really important decision
[Music]
the change
in the September 1984 elections the
Conservatives won an overwhelming
victory it was clear that the country
could not continue along Trudeau's path
the new Prime Minister Brian Mulroney
decided to reverse the situation and
began to strengthen ties with President
Ronald Reagan a new era had begun over
the next 10 years the Conservative
government did many things to improve
Canada's economy for example it lowered
taxes negotiated NAFTA the North
American Free Trade Agreement that
unites Canada the US and Mexico and
following in Margaret Thatcher's
footsteps they launched an ambitious
plan to privatize large public companies
such as air canada and petrol canada
however he didn't do one thing the most
difficult and unpopular action and that
was controlling public spending in 1990
the state held more than half of the
economy taxes were still very high and
there was a huge public deficit and
further public debt rose rapidly
conservatives had taken the easiest
measures but at the moment of truth they
hadn't really shown much commitment
therefore in the following 1993
elections Pierre Trudeau's leftist
Liberal Party on the elections again
this time promising a true revolution
could Pierre Trudeau's party save Canada
[Music]
given his backgrounds you can't deny
this would have been very difficult to
imagine but well everything was really
different at this time the new
government wanted to completely change
that country's model once and for all
and no they no longer wanted anything to
do with Moscow or the Soviet model the
main idea was that quality of life
wasn't only related to the economy it
was dependent on it if they wanted to
achieve a high quality of life they
needed to strengthen Canada's economy
and that's essentially what they did
especially under the Minister of Finance
Paul Martin the true change promoter
while the fact is that for the first few
years the leftist government launched a
sharp public spending cut eliminated
many unnecessary programs and adjusted
spending for example they strongly
reduced military spending and many
company subsidies in just two years in
real terms spending drops by 15% under
the principle which states that the
state shouldn't do things that companies
can do better the government decided to
continue with the privatisation plan in
which they went as far as privatizing
the railways and even the aviation
management system and no planes in
Canada did not fall out of the sky and
no there haven't been more accidents
than there have been in other countries
indeed on the contrary Canada's aviation
management system is considered one of
the best in the world the fact is that
in just four years the situation was
under control the government had gone
from having a huge deficit to having a
surplus I mean check out this graphic
[Music]
of course as you can imagine these
measures they weren't easy but one thing
seemed to be very clear to Canadians so
much so that in the 1997 elections the
liberal leftist party won again
by promising still more careful
government spending and on this occasion
fewer taxes as they said their role was
to protect and give opportunities to the
most disenfranchised and not to waste
everyone's money
it all seems pretty sensible don't you
think well listen to Paul Martin's words
in 2003 as he reviewed their 10 years in
power we have to build a 21st century
economy in Canada for Canadians we
succeeded in the last 10 years because
we did not deviate from our course
balanced budgets are continually
dropping debt ratio lower taxes we must
stay on that course we must be a
government committed to accountability a
government that treats taxpayers money
like it is your money Paul Merton this
revolution was a real turning point in
Canada's history
you
[Music]
[Applause]
the change of the country experienced in
the 1980s and especially in the 90s
allowed for this country's situation to
change completely Canada went from being
considered an honorary member of the
third world by The Wall Street Journal
due to its public debt problems to
becoming the most fashionable country in
the world
[Music]
the Liberal Party Hadden's only solved
the country's problems they have changed
its model in the following years up
until today all political options opted
for the Canadian model mind you Canada
is no tax haven far from it
but they have understood that companies
need to be cared for and not punished
check this out
[Music]
you heard that right if we take all
taxes the companies pay into account
this country situation is actually very
advantageous in fact Canada is one of
the few developed countries that has
been decreasing its taxes for almost 20
years to make the country more
competitive and consider for example how
company taxes have evolved
[Music]
and this policy has mostly favored the
weakest salaries have grown a lot and
this is one of the countries that
receives the most immigrants and
employment rates are very high in
addition if all of this weren't enough
in recent years Canada has also become a
world civil liberties champion as we saw
here official politic in a previous
video and this to viewer is how Canada
managed to escape its greatest crisis
and by the way just as it happened in
New Zealand and Australia these reforms
were carried out by leftist parties but
this isn't about left or right it's
about understanding that a strong
competitive and globally open economy is
the best formula to improve everyone's
quality of life but having said that now
it's your turn do you think Canada is a
good role model leave your answer in the
comments below as well as in this survey
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and every Thursday also check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]